I'll tell you this right now if they
make the robots gorgeous there will be a
war between human women and robot women
and I swear to god we will frickin win
I put Barbie dolls in the microwave till
I was 15 years old
I live to destroy a doll I don't care
about gadgets I don't respect technology
I'll kick a lexing the pussy I don't
give a shit
robot tries to take my man we're gonna
have a problem and I'll be a savage
about it - I'll wait wait I'll wait till
you fall in love with her then I'll kill
her
let's push her in the pool I don't give
a shit to me the solution for the robot
anxiety is so obvious they just have to
involve women in the designing of the
robots that's it for us to embrace the
sex robots they just have to benefit us
in some way like if a robot is gonna
have sex with my man it also just has to
be able to like make guacamole take an
avocado you just put it in our mouth
[Music]
I know I'm not a scientist I'm just
saying there's a guacamole mode we're
gonna get through this